if we look at
the human brain versus the brains or
whatever you call them
the mechanisms of intelligence in our
ancestors even early ancestors
that you write about for example in your
in your new book
what what's the difference between
the the fanciest brain we got which is
the human brain
and uh the ancestor brains that it came
from
yeah i think it depends on how far back
you want to go
you go all the way back right in your
book
so what's the interesting comparison
would you say well first of all i
wouldn't say that the human brain is the
fanciest brain we've got
i mean an octopus brain is pretty
different
and pretty fancy and they can do some
pretty amazing things that we cannot do
you know we can't grow back limbs we
can't change color
and texture we can't comport ourselves
and squeeze ourselves into a little
crevice
i mean these are things that we invent
these are like superhero abilities that
we invent
in stories right we can't do any of
those things and so
the human brain is certainly um we can
certainly do some things that other
animals can't do
that seem pretty impressive to us but
but
i would say that there there are a
number of animal brains which
seem pretty impressive to me that can do
interesting things and
really impressive things that we can't
do i mean with your work on how emotions
are made and so on you
you kind of repaint the the view of the
brain as um
as less glamorous i suppose
than you would otherwise i think or like
i guess you draw a thread that connects
all brains
uh together in terms of homeostasis and
all that kind of stuff
i yeah i wouldn't say that the that the
human brain is any
less miraculous than anybody else would
say i just think that there are
other brain structures which are also
miraculous
and i also think that there are a number
of things about the human brain which
we share with other other vertebrates
other animals with backbones
but um that are that
we share these miraculous things but we
can do some things in abundance
and we can also do some things with our
brains
together working together that other
animals
can't do or at least we haven't
discovered their ability to do it
yeah this social thing how i mean that's
one of the things you write about
what's uh how do you make sense
of the fact uh like the book sapiens and
the fact that we're able to kind of
connect like network our brains together
like you write about i'll try i'll try
to stop saying that
uh is that is that like some kind of
feature
that's built into there is that unique
to our human brains like how do you make
sense of that
what i would say is that our ability to
coordinate with each other is not unique
to humans there are lots of animals who
can do that and
we um but what we do
with that coordination is unique
because of some of the structural
features in
our brains and
it's not that adam other animals don't
have those structural features it's we
have them
in abundance so you know
the human brain is not larger than you
would expect it to be
for a primate of our size if you took
a chimpanzee and you ex
grew it to the size of a human that
chimpanzee would have
a brain that was the size of a human
brain so
there's nothing special about our brain
in terms of its size
in terms of
the um the basic blueprint
that builds our brain from an embryo
is the basic blueprint that builds all
mammalian brains and maybe even all
vertebrate brains
it's just that because of its size
and particularly because of the size of
the cerebral cortex which is the
um a part um that people mistakenly
attribute to rationality yeah mistakenly
isn't that
where all the clever stuff happens well
no it really isn't and i will also say
that lots of clever stuff happens
in animals who don't have a cerebral
cortex but right um
but uh but because of the size of the
cerebral cortex
and because of some of the features that
are
enhanced by that size that gives us the
capacity to
do things like build civilizations
and coordinate with each other not just
to
manipulate the physical world but to add
to it
in very profound ways like you know
other animals can cooperate with each
other and use
tools we draw a line in the sand
and we make countries and we even then
we create
you know uh we create citizens and
immigrants
but also ideas i mean the countries are
centered around the concept of
like ideas well my well what do you
think a citizen is an and an immigrant
those are ideas
those are ideas that we um impose on
reality and make them real
and then they have very very serious and
real effects
physical effects on people what do you
think about the idea
that a bunch of people have written
about dawkins with memes
which is like ideas are breeding like
we're just like the canvas for ideas to
breed
you know in our brains so this kind of
network that you talk about of brains
is just a little canvas for ideas to
then yeah eat against each other and so
on
i i think it's a rhetorical tool it's
cool to uh
think you know think that way so um i
think it was
michael pollan i don't remember if it
was in the botany of desire but it was
in one of his early
books on um on botany and gardening
where he wrote about
um and he wrote about uh
you know plants sort of utilizing humans
for their own
you know evolutionary purposes which is
kind of interesting you can
think about a human gut in a sense as a
propagation device for the seeds of you
know tomatoes and
what have you so it's kind of cool um so
i think
i think rhetorically it's an interesting
device but you know ideas
are as far as i know um
invented by humans propagated by humans
um so you know i i don't think they're
separate from human brains in in any way
although it would it is interesting to
to think about it that way
well of course the ideas that are using
your brain to communicate and write
excellent books
uh and they basically picked you
uh lisa as an effective communicator
and and thereby are winning so that's an
interesting world view
to think that there's particular aspects
of your brain
that are conducive to certain sets of
ideas
and maybe those ideas will win out yeah
i think the way that i would say it
really though
is that there are many species of
animals that influence
each other's nervous systems that
regulate each other's nervous systems
and they mainly do it by physical means
they do it by
chemicals scent they do it by you know
so
so termites and ants and bees for
example
use chemical scents mammals like
um like rodents use scent and they also
use
hearing audition and that little bit of
vision
primates you know non-human primates add
vision right
and i think everybody uses touch
humans as far as i know are the only
species that use
ideas and words to regulate each other
right i can text something to someone
halfway around the world
they don't have to hear my voice they
don't have to see my face
and i can have an effect on their
nervous system and
ideas the ideas that we communicate with
words
i mean words are in a sense a way for us
to do mental telepathy with each other
right i mean i'm not the first person to
say that obviously but
how do i control your heart rate how do
i control your breathing how do i
control your actions
with words it's because those words are
communicating ideas
you